so I want to tell you about a mistake I
used to make early on in my Korean I
think it can help you out and can save
you a lot of time of drama and
unnecessary issues you do not need to
have in life knowing your business I am
today not a big fan of dead weight for a
longest time I somehow someway always
had some dead weight but the dead weight
is when you and your mind know you have
a conflict with an individual but you
don't want to address it
the longer you delay that the issue gets
bigger and bigger both for you and the
other person now this is assuming this
is a person you want to have a
relationship with oh now that could be
an ego saying it which you don't you do
you're just trying to be cocky about it
I'm not talking about that I'm talking
sincerely I honestly don't want to have
a relationship with this person I'm okay
about it great that's not the person I'm
talking about I'm talking about the
person you do want to have a
relationship with that is critical for
the success of your business and it is
critical for the success of your
happiness and your life this could be
family you got to get on the phone with
them ASAP I made four calls today I made
four yesterday I had a sit down each of
them rings around an hour and a half to
three hours to an hour and a half each
call there was a conflict there they
were all different types of conflicts
there isn't a single one that was
similar to the other one not a single
one of them but they all were conflicts
we got on the phone tension in the first
17 seconds 30 seconds call continues
then it's solid then it's open you're
open I want to talk about it are you
open to it yeah let's talk about it
listen this matters to me if it matters
to you let's address it great there was
things that I'll sit in this alyssum I'm
not comfortable with this decision that
we made okay great
yeah I'm not comfortable with the
decision we made here this is my
thoughts you want me to tell you my
thoughts or you just want to be kind of
keep it to myself no share with me your
thoughts here's why I think about this
well here's what I think about this
great there is a resolution if you're
willing right in my career eventually I
got to a point I said listen I don't
have any time for this I'm getting on
the phone making these calls if they
matter 95% of the calls I made and I got
on the phone with the individual and we
addressed the dead weight 95% of the
time we solved it a hundred percent of
the time when I didn't call it it was
always wrong and it got worse and worse
and worse so my suggestion to you this
is my weekly challenge to you today you
know who those two or three people are
that you need to have a conversation
with today make a list
hollom right now don't be afraid and
forget about this video make the call
right now all the distractions get them
away from you call those people one by
one by one and see how they go I can
tell you 9 out of 10 times you're gonna
be glad you made those calls once you
make those calls send me a tweet at
Patrick bet David and just tell me one
how it felt and 2 what was their
reaction when you made those difficult
calls that you needed to have and by the
way if you haven't subscribed to this
channel yet click on the subscribe
button below and if you want to join a
notification squad click on that alert
button right next to it you'll be one
the first to get the videos when they
come up thank you everybody
bye bye